understand how to prioritize so one of
the biggest things I find with
entrepreneurs is is trying to manage
your time balancing your time it's super
easy to get distracted by things it's
super easy to let work time bleed into
personal time to have no time for
yourself and to be constantly stressed
out because you're everything from the
janitor to the CEO and your business and
one of the things that I find really
helpful is giving myself constrictions
of time in which I'm forced to work on a
certain project and it forces me to only
do what's most important because
otherwise it'll bleed into other time
that then takes away from other things
going on and work on so sometimes it'll
be a 90-minute chunk and I need to make
sure whatever I'm getting done gets done
in that 90-minute chunk and sometimes
it'll be a day so money is for example I
work on my Toronto dance house of
business everything that has to get done
for the week happens on that Monday and
so it forces me to really be a focus and
prioritize on big things it's an
important exercise that I would
encourage you guys to try because again
otherwise you're going to find yourself
working late into every night not have
an impersonal time because you're just
trying to do everything you just let
things bleed where you could find a lot
more opportunity in your schedule your
calendar by making sure your focus and
focus on the right things and having
that time time constraint really helps
so as relates to my book is I I went
traveling i was in orlando on my annual
disney trip with the family I got sick
so I'm excuse any coffee that comes up I
have medication because I have a major
ear infection i developed there and
starting to feel better and I one of the
things i hate about traveling is that
messes up my schedule right so i came
home on a monday which meant i missed my
monday toronto the insults a day and
that's frustrating because i had a lot
of stuff that i need to get done and so
how this place in my book is that
tuesday stews my book writing day we had
a mini crisis with Toronto dance salsa
that had to deal with and so that became
my tuesday so i didn't write on tuesday
there wasn't anything super urgent for
the
I'm still waiting on my publisher to get
back to me about the edits I haven't
really forced the issue mostly because
they didn't have time to deal with it
and I need to get on that horse a little
bit for the next week and so being faced
with that decision I've got one day and
I've got two things to worry about
either I do the book or do trono dance
salsa or I try to do both of them and
you got to understand the priorities and
so for me at that time it was ok I need
to get this Toronto dance also stuff
done I'll worry about the book next week
and I think you're constantly faced with
these kinds of battles and it's worth
sometimes putting yourself in those
situations because you'll find that
you're spending a lot of time on things
that aren't really that important when
something that happens in your personal
life or you go traveling or you know
just something comes up the messes up
your schedule you end up doing the
things that you have to do not the
things that are kind of nice to do and a
lot of times i found this with me that i
drop those things that are nice to do
permanently like it just wasn't worth
doing so I think it's worth putting
yourself in that situation every now and
then it's uncomfortable it sucks but you
learned from it and it helps you create
a better schedule alright I'm going to
get onto the questions first one came in
Federico hi Evan question in what
formats will you both be available paper
PDF ebook audiobook asking because I
just got to know audible from amazon a
few weeks ago and be great to have your
book they're also narrated by yourself
what do you think so i've talked of this
a few times the book we got we got the
approval to get a deluxe ebook version
and an audiobook version which is rare
for a first-time author so that's
awesome i'm super excited about it i am
going to insist that i read it i hate
hearing books from authors that are not
read by the author I think it's one the
authors either lazy or too they just
don't have the voice to do it or the
charisma personality to do it I still
think I think I would be good i can't
imagine i can't imagine anybody else you
get in my book I will I don't see a
reason why the publisher wouldn't want
me to do it I think it just makes sense
but if they don't I'm gonna fight like
crazy for it just yeah I'm gonna be
upset if they don't so long and I me
that's going to be a huge battle if I
don't but again I think it's going to be
something that is just a no-brainer for
me to do so yeah so I'm
Bart marketing the book mode yet but
when i get there i'm going to really
appreciate your feedback and comments
and suggestions on it Amanda more
content about hustling while you wait
would be great it's so painful depend on
others for your next move also what are
the best idea geez to build an audience
from scratch for your book deal and
promo besides youtube so last week my
topic was hustling while you wait you
know sometimes you have to wait for
people to get things done and not just
sitting on your thumbs waiting but going
out and doing something and taking
action to move your goals forward I
think what helps there is just to kind
of go deeper and give you a little bit
more context I think as an entrepreneur
projects that you worked on right you
you know so you have three different
buckets three big projects that you're
working on I'd be looking at okay if I'm
waiting on one person to give back to me
for this project is there another way
did I can move that project forward so
if I'm looking at the book okay I'm
waiting on my my editor to get back to
me so what else can I do for the book
can I research other people who've done
great audio books kind of research
people who have done great book launches
can I create more content around my book
for my youtube channel you know just
building up momentum for that project so
that when i get an answer back I don't
have to wait to start all the other
things right so I can do things in
parallel while I'm waiting the other
option is said if I'm you know if I'm
waiting on bucket one for somebody then
I start working on bucket to work on the
next project we're going the other thing
that you have going on in parallel just
the point is I know it's sucks waiting
on on people especially when there's a
you know big deal that you're waiting on
or big client or a big media thing that
you're waiting no I preparing for a big
presentation is really suck watch for
hate wait I think people hate waiting in
general but entrepreneurs especially we
are doers we want other people to be
doers and we're frustrated when they are
not as much of a doer as we are it's
frustrating so don't wait just do
something else and as frustrated as it
is recognized that you're moving your
projects forward in another capacity I
just look at your schedule and say hey
I'm going to move another one of my
projects forward in terms of building an
audience from scratch for a book deal
and promotion that's not on YouTube when
you are trying to get a book deal the
thing that they are looking at
especially for a first-time author is
your audience because the the publisher
wants to know that you're going to be
able to promote the book and they want
to see that you have an audience
promoted to youtube is my favorite place
to be one because of the sheer size of
the the place of the audience over
billion active users every month which
is insane and two because video lends
itself well to my strengths I would
rather do a video interview than write
out an interview with somebody and so
when people asked me to do an interview
I had one earlier today I guess when
this video goes live won't be earlier
today but anyway my default response
when somebody has to do an interview
with me or podcast with me is that's
awesome would love to do it let's make
you a video on my channel and it helps
to give them exposure to so I would
think it's figuring out what platform
best fits your strengths so if you're
really good on writing then maybe you
should have a block or maybe you should
be on Twitter and go all in if you're
really great at taking pictures and
maybe you should be on Instagram
Facebook if you're really good at
interviewing people and you like
narrating you like talking but you don't
want to be on camera maybe start a
podcast the point is you leverage your
strengths to the medium the best fits
the audience that you're going after and
again what you're really good at doing
yourself so YouTube would be my default
because of the size and my strengths it
doesn't have to be YouTube but the worst
thing you can do is try to do everything
it is that's what that's what a lot of
people do is like I got to be on YouTube
and Facebook and Twitter and Instagram
and everything and you do everything
half ass and you get no results from
it's a god that social media stuff
doesn't work where it's better to find
the one thing that you feel really fits
your audience and your strengths and go
all in on that and then you can branch
out if you need to but don't feel like I
have to be everywhere because that's the
path to being mediocre next one
sensation Co Minh I've been still
waiting on Michelle Obama's ten rules
for success you know all of the videos
that I make the top ten the answer
presses their requests from you guys
from the audience and there's a lot of
requests we have unloaded now we have
1200 1257 requests right now and we're
making for top 10 videos per week so
it's going to take a long time to fill
up and so know when Michelle Obama's
going to come up I know she's on our
list I know what will people have
requested her it's coming I promise but
don't freak out if it doesn't come
instantly because we have
of a lot of requests and i love the
requests and keep them commenting and
sometimes people get upset when it
doesn't come instantly like there's a
lot of requests and it's a lot of work
to put those together right like you
guys get to enjoy a 10 to 20 minute clip
but we've got to sift through hours and
hours and hours and hours of research to
find that best 10 to 20 minute clip so
it's coming have some patience don't
freak out on me next leaves liev i hope
i pronounced that ok ? entrepreneur
without a budget so the pens what kind
of budget we're talking about we're
talking zero budget did I be looking at
volunteers I'd be looking at interns I
built my business the start of assertive
I'm caricom was off of high school turns
I had high school interns and foreign
language interns who are helping me up
the website dealing with authors and
customers high school students have to
come for their credit so you have to you
have to teach them and mentor them and
give them assignments and foreign
language people come because they're
trying to learn English and they want to
work at ironmen in English so there's
pros and cons like the pro is that
they're free and they have to do the
work to get the credit that they're
looking for but you have to remember
that you can't just give off an
assignment and let them do their thing
you have to mentor them and coach them
and train them and be their be available
for them as well don't just look at it
is one way it's gotta be it's gotta be
both a still I said that's a investment
of time and sometimes the time isn't
worth it you know sometimes the juice is
not worth the squeeze sometimes the
amount of work that goes into training
and mentoring somebody is so much that
you're not getting a return and so
that's there's a downside to having free
labor as well if you have a small budget
I'd be looking at using up work I have a
team on up work I don't know how many
people are way up work now ten people
maybe more the 16 of us so probably more
it's basically people who work remotely
the first guy I hired a heart for one
hour day and that was one hour that
freed up more than hour of my time
because he was better what I was doing
and you can hire people overseas for a
really good rate and for them it's a
really good way to like you think you
could hire somebody for four or five
dollars us an hour and you may take four
or five dollars us an hour that's that's
it
see like these guys should be earning
more but in their countries that's a
really good rate to earn you know some
of the people that I've hired used to
have to drive an hour to get to work or
take the train for an hour to get to
work and now to train for an hour to get
back from work doing call center job
that they hated and getting paid half of
what they're going to pay with me so you
get to work from home gets a mcdouble
and they're doing work that they like
and so yet be five dollars an hour paint
lahaska pay more for the video
production and the other stuff but you
don't need to have a big budget to get
started you could hire somebody for an
hour a day or two hours a day or a
couple hours a week to help alleviate
some of the task so when you say without
a budget maybe this room for a tiny
budget to free up your time to do bigger
things she continued on one of the best
sources to use I know about five or but
takes so much time to find them
organized I use up work that's my
favorite place to go I've done some
stuff on the fiber when I do it though I
look for somebody that I could ideally
transition as somebody being long term I
just recently got one of my so are two
of my youtube videos transcribed on
fiber and she's a good job i'm looking
at turning out into a long-term
relationship so you'll have to log into
fiber each time to do it there are some
fun stuff that you can do in five or two
which I like doing surprising people on
my team every now and then but if I had
to pick a place to find people to be on
my team long term i definitely look it
up work been on with them for a couple
years I'm not a feeling with them in any
way apart from meeting a really happy
customer and definitely you're a
definitely recommend that for anybody
who's trying to build a team where you
don't have to have them close to you how
do i select which part of my activity to
delegate first so for that one I'd be
looking at where are you spending your
time that you feel as a low leverage is
low leverage for you what are you
working on in your day-to-day activities
that if you could free up that our and
give it to somebody else it's it's like
for example data entry or administrative
work something that is not at the CEO if
you look at all the tasks I'm janitor to
CEO where is that the task fall on that
plate and you want to play up here as
much as possible you can't do your solo
entrepreneur you're not going to be CEO
time one hundred percent of the time
that's not going to happen but you want
to play up here as much as you can
because that's the high-value stuff that
you're among the best in the word
that's going to help you grow your
business the challenges for
entrepreneurs you're spending so much
time down here doing the low paying work
that you never have the time to focus on
really building something amazing so the
stuff you want to delegate especially
the start is the stuff that's down here
that's taking up a check of your time so
admin work accounting work I mean
account is one of the first things a lot
of people will outsource and delegates
it could be some of the marketing for
your business anything that that you
can't automate things be done by person
but it shouldn't be done by you and I
just be looking at anybody do is look at
your schedule look at your look at a
typical week for you and outline where
are you spending your time and then how
much of that is high leverage versus low
leverage and the low leverage stuff
maybe you just get rid of it may be that
it shouldn't be delegated to anybody out
it should just be gone this is not high
value and then look to automate it and
then if you can't automate it then you
look to delegate it follow that process
then you can hopefully free up big
chunks of your calendar to focus on the
higher leverage stuff Tamra is asking
what kind of surprises do you find on
the fiber I do some fun stuff here so as
an example I had a there was a guy who
would climb a coconut tree and throw
down a coconut and on the coconut is a
message and so I would send I would for
example create one for my programmer and
say you are the best programmer a deal
or thank you for your programming the
deal so I send in this video and he's
like what is happening there's a guy
climbing a coconut tree throwing it down
and then the surprises at the end that
has this message there are other ones
where they'll put a message up on a on a
Jumbotron at a stadium or this guy like
deep-sea diving underwater and turns
over a shell and there's a message on it
and they just do it through their their
animation right like they're not
actually doing that each time i thought
the coconut tree guy is each time which
is interesting I had a guy I dress up
not dress up he's basically he's wearing
a thong and and he rubs chocolate sauce
all over him while he sings happy
birthday I sent that to one of my
friends so I love the fun silly stuff
because there's so much so much boring
stuff that happens in you know running a
business and in day-to-day life that
it's fun to have something different and
unique
there's a lot of those kind of fun
things that you can do there was a guy
who you can do sometimes for marketing
to I had a guy who is a kid eight years
old a 10 years old who would wear a
shirt with a message on it as long as
his mother would approve the message
right it can't be something dirty
because he's got to wear it to school
every day and he would wear this shirt
for five days during a week at school so
I gave him an Evan Carmichael shirt and
he wore that the school I like
supporting entrepreneurs so I like I
like the fun stuff and for the practical
business stuff I've used it for
transcribing translating videos I
haven't done too much on the business
side thinking about it because I prefer
to hire people longer-term using up work
so thanks for the question you can have
some fun with but did you you can get
lost at the five or two there's so many
fun things you can realize that like two
hours of your day is going on so just
watch out for that can you have simple
tips like a simple system on how to
start taking care of what to delegate I
noticed that it's not obvious to make
the first necessary small step and then
the next small step 2 looks to find
somebody could you explain that in
simple words i made a video on timish
moyers channel and video creators about
how to hire people in up work and i
think that is probably the best thing to
look at I've made a few on my channel
too but that's the most recent one I
think it's for the best thing I look
through because I go step by step my
process which is also a weird process
different than most people most people
hire for the wrong things end up with
the wrong candidate end up getting
frustrated and then then it's like I
know this person I'm not going to hire
somebody so I'm going to go back to
doing it myself which isn't the right
strategy because you can't build
something great if you're doing it all
on your own so just because your first
hire didn't work out a lot that prevent
you from going out and hiring somebody
else your process is probably broken i
believe the prop the hiring process is
broken for most companies so that video
should help and it addresses a lot more
than i could do in a couple minutes here
question from too helpful guys hey Evan
we love the content you are putting out
around the book it's building our
anticipation and we can't wait until you
put it out cool that's the part of it I
mean part of making these videos were 12
docked with the process to make it easy
for anybody who is starting to write
their own blog to see what goes into it
you know i'm working with pink random
house
you want to work with a major publisher
this series kind of outlines how that
works this is episode 44 so you can go
back and see how everything is gone from
the start and also it helps build
anticipation builds excitement for me to
like this is a long process before the
book comes out and it's great to have
you guys with me and they give you
updates every week and how things are
going and it keeps me motivated and
excited as well i think is a good lesson
in that whatever things you're working
on behind the scenes you can let people
in on that and it's it's good motivation
for you and for them and is good
marketing as well so whatever next big
project you're working on don't just
release the finish thing but but let
people tag along the journey the
struggle is the ops downs and it gets
them interested people like that little
behind-the-scenes look so this is my
test and it's worked out well I
encourage you to look at it for your own
business and the question was do you
have any tips for delegation when you
don't have employees may be virtual
assistants outsourcing us some kind yeah
I don't think you should jump into a
full-time hire at the start I think it's
a big mistake I think if you don't know
how to manage you've never managed
somebody before and you're a startup and
you don't have the budget that you know
you put a lot of money into one
full-time person that's a big risk and
it's a big learning curve for you and
how to measure that person I much prefer
to crawl before I walk before I run and
I would recommend hiring somebody for
125 hours a week to test one your
ability to delegate to your
communication and being able to pass
information on and off and three can you
get results from that person like does
it at the beginning it doesn't free up
your time you think I'm going to hire
somebody to free up my time as a sudden
doesn't fear every time because of all
the training that has to go into it and
so ideally you start with a project that
is easy for them to pick up and then you
give them more and more responsibilities
with time and not just like boo a lot of
munchers just dump all of their stuff on
the first employee and they get
overwhelmed then that person has
understand everything and then you get
frustrated and it doesn't work out so
something easy something small something
short it tests your ability to manage
somebody on a small scale and let them
prove themselves let them show that they
can add value to your business it is
immensely satisfying and freeing once
they pick it up right to know that this
is getting taken care of and it doesn't
have to be you all the time doing it is
an amazing feeling but it does take some
time to to get to so again for that I'd
recommend checking out the video on Tim
Schmoyer ears channel when the video
disc of it this video goes on youtube
I'll link it up in the description too
so you guys can check it out that's it
so I'd love to hear your thoughts your
questions about the topic of
prioritizing and if you have a thought
or question about my book about the book
writing process leave in the comments
below and I'll answer it on next week's
video thank you guys so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon